[Music]
for centuries it was well known that the
health of one's soul required people to
spend periods away from the city
somewhere isolated peaceful and
spiritual it's this impasse that
explains why for centuries all the major
religions built monasteries beautiful
pieces of architecture in quiet places
the school of life is a global
organization committed to psychological
health and well-being our headquarters
are in some of the world's major urban
centres London Paris Amsterdam Melbourne
Seoul Istanbul but we've always longed
to be able to help our audiences from
around the world find some other peace
of mind
once offered by monasteries it was with
this in mind that the school of life got
interested in the work of the great
British architect John Paulson who's
designed several monasteries churches
and places of contemplation the result
of our collaboration is now open a
beautiful secular monastic building in
the middle of a deserted rugged Valley
in central Wales the school of life's
secular monastery that we call simply
the life helps
[Music]
the Lifehouse has three large bedrooms
each dedicated to one of the great ways
that humans have over the centuries salt
serenity the literature room is entirely
oriented to reading and has a carefully
curated library decked out with books
that we've chosen
next comes the music room equipped with
a state-of-the-art music equipment and a
selection of some of the best
therapeutic relaxing music of the world
finally there's the bathing room a
bedroom with a large sunken bath in it
with vistas on to the Welsh countryside
in all directions
[Music]
the house includes a contemplation
chamber buried deep in the hillside
where you can sit alone and listen to
water trickling into a fountain and
collect your thoughts and comments the
school of life's always been dedicated
to mental well-being with the launch of
our life house we've taken the best
lessons from the monastic traditions of
old and updated them for the modern age
do come and stay
[Music]
you